Why did no one say
anything have you noticed that things
got weird a few years ago that the world
makes less and less sense with every
year that goes by why did protesters in
England where the police are not armed
shout hands up don't shoot at cops who
don't carry guns isn't it strange that
within the blink of an eye politicians
suddenly became unable to explain what a
woman is a woman can have a penis I'm
not I don't think we can conduct this
debate with you know sorry offended you
no no no it's just how is it that
societies whose stated goal was a world
in which all men are created equal
became obsessed with dividing themselves
along racial lines Why do multinational
corporations stick rainbow Flags
everywhere except in Saudi Arabia
obviously do you remember when everyone
lost their ship because Donald Trump
said we simply cannot allow people to
pour into the United States undetected
undocumented unchecked and circumventing
the line of people who are waiting
patiently diligently and lawfully to
become immigrants in this country you
probably don't because it wasn't
president Trump that said it it was
President Obama and no one lost their
[__] because up until 3 minutes ago
everyone left and right understood that
countries need borders and yet here we
are in 2023 where the definition of a
woman is now controversial people
breaking into our country illegally is
conflated with normal lawful immigration
and the weird obsession with race just
won't go away and what's strange about
it is that if you talk to most people no
one wanted this so how did it happen and
why did no one say anything around 2013
2014 social media platforms like Twitter
and Facebook began to take off virtually
overnight the mainstream media began to
publish article after article about
racism sexism homophobia transphobia Etc
and this didn't just happen in Britain
in America it happened in places as far
and wide as Nigeria Japan Cuba the
Philippines Qatar and Brazil the
investor charie Munga who's Warren
Buffett's right-hand man said show me
the incentives and I'll show you the
outcome what no one realized at the time
is that social media rewards certain
types of communication and whatever you
reward you get more of social media
rewards complaining outrage and
victimhood so it produces complaints
outrage porn and victims Why did no one
say anything well first of all some
people tried to JK Rowling said
something and went from celebrated
author to demonized hate figure Barry
Vice a journalist at the New York Times
said something she's no longer at the
New York Times clinical psychologist
Jordan Peterson said something and now
they're trying to take his license to
practice away and despite their efforts
little changed as institution after
institution succumb to the craziness
that in itself is weird I often found
myself naively thinking that all it
takes is one more more Brave principled
an articulate individual to stand up and
say something and it would all be over
instead one after another these people
lost jobs opportunities and careers it's
going on right now with Rasheen Murphy
who dared to suggest that puberty
blockers are a bad idea the BBC
responded by removing her work from
their Radio lineup this is despite the
fact that the Tavistock Clinic which
administered these puberty blockers was
shut down after the cast review raised
serious concerns about giving these
drugs to children and despite the fact
that most people in both Britain and
America do not support puberty blockers
gender reassignment surgery the
inclusion of trans women and women
sports and so on in other words
prominent respected and successful
people who speak the truth are punished
for saying what most of their fellow
citizens believe does that make any
sense to you to anyone so what's going
on people will often use clever sounding
phrases like institutional capture to
explain it but what does that mean
exactly the BBC wasn't physically
overrun by Barbarian horde and I can
tell you from personal experience that
not everyone at these institutions
agrees with what's happening I once took
part in a debate on the BBC in
preparation for which I had a call with
the producer in the conversation she
told me how alarmed she herself was by
what was going on but she refused to
speak up for herself part of this is
group think which is when people agree
to go along with something because they
prioritize Harmony within the group over
making the right decision they keep
quiet because they know the majority
disagree with them and they don't want
to be the black sheep of the group but a
related and even more interesting
phenomenon is the abalene Paradox the
term was introduced by management expert
Jeremy Harvey in the 1970s it's based on
a story he used to tell about a family
which is sitting around comfortably
playing dominoes in the heat when one of
them suggests taking a long trip to
abalene Texas for dinner thinking that's
what everyone wants the individual
family members all agreed to go it is
only when they return from a hot Dusty
unpleasant trip that they gradually
realize that none of them actually
wanted to go they went along not because
they were in the minority but because
they all thought they were in the
minority but we are not in the minority
those of us who believe that children
can't consent to Serious medical
interventions the rational debate is
better than name calling the countries
need borders that freedom of expression
is better than censorship we're in the
majority that's why we need the JK
rowlings Barry vicces and Jordan
Petersons of the world they shatter the
illusion of consensus and give us a
fighting chance against the tyranny of
the minority and this is why the way to
end cancel culture is to embrace the
cancelled to make sure that people who
speak are rewarded for it and to
encourage others to say enough if you
enjoy these monologues make sure to head
on over to my substack And subscribe you
can read them there weeks ahead of
[Music]
time